I think Pelosi uh you know even though
I'm going to show you a clip in just a
sec the media is still fawning all over
her for what she accomplished or I guess
purported to accomplish whether we like
it or not
um you know I think she'll mostly be
remembered for being hyper partisan and
once again just delivering more power to
the government and less power to you
here's Mika Brzezinski on the televised
mental institution known as MSNBC on how
we should just honor that great woman
Nancy Pelosi no it's the end of an era
and an incredible one and um I mean
whether you're a Republican or a
Democrat it's sort of hard not to be in
awe of what she has accomplished unless
you're in a cult uh coming up we'll get
much more reaction
I mean I just don't know what did she
accomplish like she accomplished getting
rid of trump she accomplished impeaching
Trump wasting a ton of time with the
January 6th earrings uh getting us into
a recession you know voting endlessly
for more and more money to Ukraine like
trying to give the devil to do here what
did she really really accomplish I'm not
sure I mean I guess they got their
inflation reduction Act passed
um didn't produce inflation but like you
know I guess she got more diversity and
Equity probably into the system of the
federal government but she's telling us
we're in a culture okay